>>> WHAT DOES MIKE END SELL BEE
SIDS PILLOWS?
HE SELLS FALSE HOPE AND DONALD
TRUMP IS HELPING HIM.
FALSE HOPE IS A COMBUSTAL THING.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU WHAT LENDL IS
DOING IN HIS FAR RIGHT CORNER OF
THE WEB AND HOW IT AFFECTS
EVERYBODY ELSE.
LINDELL IS A FORMER CHRISTIAN
AND INTERNET TYCOON.
HE BUILT A FORTUNE AND WAS
REWARDED WITH TRUMP ACCESS AND
AIR TIME.
HE EVEN ENDORSED THE PILLOWS.
TRUMP WAS AN INSIDER AND HE
LOVED IT.
NOW BOTH MEN ARE ON THE OUTSIDE,
BUT NOT FOR LONG, LINDELL
CLAIMS.
WITH THE ENERGY OF AN OFFICER OR
PREACHER, HE SPOUTS THE LAW, THE
COUNTRY HAS A REAL PRESIDENT AND
THE RESULTS WILL BE OVERTURNED
SOME WAY, SOMEHOW.
HE SAYS THIS ON LINDELL'S TV,
HIS HOME FOR TRUE BELIEVERS.
WATCH THE ENTRANCE TO HIS SHOW
AND NOTICE THE REFERENCE FOR
HOPE, THAT HE PROVIDES HOPE.
>> THIS IS THE LINDELL REPORT,
BRINGING YOU NEWS COMBINED WITH
HOPE BY ACTING PROFITABLE AND
ACHIEVABLE ACTION POINTS TO
ASSIST YOU IN DEFENDING AND
PRESERVING FAITH AND FREEDOMS.
NOW, HERE IS YOUR HOST, MIKE
LINDELL.
>> HELLO, EVERYBODY.
>> IT'S LIKE "THE DAILY SHOW,"
RIGHT?
BUT THIS SHOW IS WHERE LINDELL
RAILS AGAINST LAST YEAR'S
ELECTION AND ATTACKS THE VOTING
COMPANY SUING HIM AND CLAIMS
CHINA RIGGED EVERYTHING AGAINST
TRUMP.
HE KEEPS KICKING THE CAN DOWN
THE OLD ROAD, FIRST SUGGESTING
TRUMP WILL BE BACK IN OFFICE IN
MAY, THEN AUGUST, NOW NOVEMBER.
HE CLAIMS HE'S HEADING TO THE
SUPREME COURT WITH A CASE THEY
WILL JUST HAVE TO HEAR.
>> SO NOW IT'S GETTING FILED A
WEEK FROM TUESDAY.
IT'S THIS THICK.
IT'S DIFFERENT.
IT'S NOT WHAT WAS FILED BEFORE.
>> AS YOU CAN SEE THERE, HE'S
DISHING THIS STUFF OUT AT
CONFERENCES, ON LIVESTREAMS, ON
WEBCASTS.
HE EVEN SAYS HE'S MEETING WITH
ATTORNEYS GENERAL IN VARIOUS
STATES.
LINDELL HAS AN ENTIRE UNIVERSE
OF THIS STUFF.
24-HOUR FEED ON HIS WEBSITE, HIS
OWN VERSION OF YOUTUBE, AND IT'S
ALL PART OF THIS BROADER FAR
RIGHT BRAND.
WHEN OTHER MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA
SCRUTINIZE IT, HE SCREAMS.
>> THE EVIDENCE IS OUT!
IT'S GOING TO BE TOO LATE TO
CLOSE THE GATE, SO ALL YOU DAILY
BEES, POLITICAL INSIDERS,
POLITICALS, YAHOOS, RACHEL
MADDOWS AND MSNBC, ALL OF YOU,
IT'S OVER!
>> AND HE RESERVES HIS HARSHEST
WORDS FOR FOX NEWS, WHICH HE
SAID IS TOO AFRAID TO TELL THE
TRUTH ABOUT THE ELECTION.
>> FOX IS THE WORST MEDIA OUTLET
IN PROBABLY THE HISTORY OF THE
PLANET.
WHY DON'T YOU HELP SAVE OUR
COUNTRY?
WHY DON'T YOU TALK ABOUT THE
2020 ELECTION AND GET RID OF
THESE MACHINES?
YOUR COUNTRY IS GONE.
YOUR WORST THAN ALL OF THE LEFT
MEDIA PUT TOGETHER.
SHAME ON FOX.
>> YET HE STILL BUYS LOTS OF AIR
TIME ON FOX FOR HIS PILLOWS.
HE TRIED TO BOYCOTT FOX FOR A
WHILE AND THEN CAME CRAWLING
BACK.
THIS IS LINDELL LAND, ALT RIGHT
RABBIT HOLE WAY, WAY DEEPER THAN
FOX NEWS WHERE ELECTION
SUBVERSION AND MYPILLOWS ARE
SOLD HAND IN HAND.
DIAMOND AND SILK HAVE A SHOW HIS
NETWORK AND THEY DRINK OUT OF
THEIR TRUMP WON COFFEE MUGS
WHILE HOSTING A SHOW.
WATCH.
>> USE PRIMO CODE TRUMP ONE TO
GET UP TO 66% OFF YOUR ENTIRE
PURCHASE.
>> BECAUSE YOU ALL KNOW HE WON.
>> EVEN THE ADS, EVEN THE GRIST
REINFORCES THE LIE TRUMP IS THE
RIGHTFUL PRESIDENT.
THIS IS THE FALSE HOPE LINDELL
PRESENTS.
IT'S A DANGEROUS THING.
YOU CAN HEAR IT WHEN HIS FANS
CALL IN TO HIS SHOW.
THEY CALL IN AND SOMETIMES SAY
THEIR DEVOTION TO LINDELL AND
THE BIG LIE HAS ALIENATED THEM
FROM FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
>> MR. LINDELL, I'M SO -- I'M SO
HAPPY, SO MUCH ENERGY, YOU GIVE
ME HOPE EVERY DAY.
>> MIKE, YOU ARE ACTUALLY ANGELS
IN DISGUISE.
>> I ALWAYS GET BADGERED ONLINE
WHENEVER I BRING YOUR NAME UP,
PEOPLE ON THE LIBERAL SIDE THINK
I'M AN IDIOT, I'M DUMB FOR
FOLLOWING YOU.
>> LINDELL'S TRUTH PROBLEM IS A
PROBLEM FOR ALL OF US.
WHILE SOME PARTS OF THE GOP AND
GOP MEDIA HAVE TRIED TO HUSH THE
BIG LIE, LINDELL IS LOUDER THAN
EVER, AND TRUMP IS RIGHT THERE
WITH HIM.
AS I BURY THE LEAD, THIS WEEK
LINDELL SAYS HE'S AIRING A
40-MINUTE INTERVIEW WITH THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
OF COURSE, NATURALLY, LINDELL
DOES A LOT OF THE TALKING.
>> YOU GO BACK TO NOVEMBER 4th,
AND WE ALL LIVED THIS TWILIGHT
ZONE, I ALWAYS SAY, THERE WAS AN
OLD SAYING IF A TREE FALLS IN
THE FOREST AND NO ONE HEARD IT,
DID IT REALLY FALL, THE MEDIA
TELLS US THERE IS NO FOREST.
>> THIS STUFF IS THE REAL
TWILIGHT ZONE AND IT'S BEING
ENDORSED BY THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
SO LINDELL HAS POWER, EVEN
THOUGH HE'S OFTEN THIS FAR RIGHT
LOONY-TUNES LAND, HE HAS POWER
AND HE'S USING IT VIA HIS
LIVESTREAMS EVERY DAY.
ZACHARY PETRIZZO IS BACK WITH
ME, "DAILY BEAST" MEDIA
REPORTER.
ZACH, YOU WATCHED ALL OF THESE
LINDELL TV SHOWS.
YOU HAVE WRITTEN ABOUT THEM AT
YOUR PRIOR JOB AT SALON AND NOW
YOU'RE DOING THIS AT "THE DAILY
BEAST."
HOW DO YOU KEEP YOUR HEAD
STRAIGHT WHEN YOU'RE COVERING
RIGHT WING RADICALIZATION AS A
REPORTER?
>> GREAT QUESTION.
FOR ME, I ALWAYS TRY TO KEEP
PERSPECTIVE ON IT.
WE HAVE A DELUSIONAL PILLOW
SALESMAN AND WE HAVE A FORMER
PRESIDENT, TWICE IMPEACHED
PRESIDENT, WHO IS COUPE
FRIENDLY.
THOSE TWO THINGS DON'T EXACTLY
MATCH UP SUPER WELL AND THIS
INTERVIEW COMING UP ON TUESDAY
WITH HIM AND THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS QUITE INTERESTING
AND I THINK RIGHT WING MEDIA
KIND OF HAS A PROBLEM ON THEIR
HANDS.
AS SOME, LIKE THE WASHINGTON
EXAMINER KIND OF KEEP AN ARM'S
LENGTH AWAY FROM MIKE LINDELL
AND YOU HAVE THE GATEWAY PUNDIT,
THIS CON SPIRITTORIAL FAR RIGHT
SITE REALLY PUSH LINDELL'S
THEORIES.
>> YOU'RE SAYING HE DOES HAVE
AMPLIFICATION EVEN OUTSIDE HIS
OWN WEBSITE, OUTSIDE OF ALL OF
THOSE WEB SHOWS HE HAS PEOPLE
HOSTING AND HE DOES GET SOME
PICKUP, EVEN THOUGH OUTLETS LIKE
FOX ARE WARY OF HIM?
>> ABSOLUTELY, YEAH.
OF COURSE, THE GATEWAY PUNDIT
WILL PRETTY MUCH PUBLISH
ANYTHING THAT LINDELL SPEWS
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY,
THERE'S A FINANCIAL INCENTIVE.
THE GATEWAY PUNDIT AND ALL OF
THESE OTHER SITES HAVE A
MYPILLOW PROMO CODE AND GETTING
A LOT OF MONEY, PART OF THIS
REVENUE SHARING, EVERY TIME THEY
SELL A PILLOW, THEY GET $30 OF
IT.
SO IT'S PRETTY FINANCIALLY --
THERE'S AN INCENTIVE THERE.
>> SO HOLD ON, IS IT JUST A
ADRIFT, IS THAT ALL IT IS?
>> TO SOME EXCEPT IT IS ADRIFT
BUT LINDELL IS PUSHING WITHOUT
QUESTION.
HE'S REALLY BOUGHT INTO IT.
I WOULD GET CALLS FROM MIKE
LINDELL AT 2:00 IN THE MORNING
BEFORE HIS FAILED AUGUST CYBER
SYMPOSIUM.
SO I REALLY DO BELIEVE HE'S ALL
IN HERE.
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF NOW
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENS WITH THIS
DOMINION SUIT AND ALL OF THESE
OTHER PIECES.
>> AND HE'S IN LINE TO ACCEDE
BANNON, SIMULTANEOUSES BANNON'S
PODCAST.
IT'S THIS UNIVERSE THAT'S
FURTHER RIGHT OF FOX THAT THE
REST OF US NEED TO BE AWAR